[Music]
this
is star talk neil degrasse tyson here
your personal astrophysicist
this is going to be a cosmic queries
edition on the subject
of mushrooms we're going to find out
where they come from what they're doing
and why
and especially what is their
relationship to humans
and i got matt kirsten as my co-host
matt how you doing man
i'm very good neil how's it going it's
been too long dude
yeah it's nice to be back i miss you and
and your host of
did i get it right probably science that
is exactly it ah it's getting great this
time
excellent i'm a one-time guest on your
show um
emphasis on one time we would have you
back in a heartbeat i
i i never want to abuse my connections
your access
privileges yeah okay but i love it when
you're
out there just bringing science to the
public in a whole other way
and you're an important sort of cog in a
wheel that we're all trying to keep
turning here
i appreciate that we definitely are
doing it in another way to uh the people
who really know their stuff
and even if it's only probably science
i'm still good with that
well i think neither you or i or our
mushroom expert
although i've eaten a few in my day
that's very true
we combed the world to find one of the
world's experts maybe
the world's experts on this subject and
it's merlin
sheldrake merlin welcome to star talk
thanks for having me neil it's good to
be here yeah so that accent that places
you right in london right now is that
where you're coming from that's right so
you're an ecologist
like a mushroom ecologist you're also
author uh your book just came out in
paperback i think
the hardcover came out last year but
often paperbacks do much better than the
hardback so
this will be anyone's chance to pick
this up and and you can't miss it
if you you want this book if you if you
love mushrooms
even if you don't love mushrooms but
wonder what the hell
are those things coming out of the
ground entangled life
how fungi make our worlds
change our minds and shape our futures
that is
ambitious dude uh so before we get to
our
our q a with our uh fan base
i just want to sort of lay some
groundwork here so
if you can tell us oh but just sorry let
me finish your pedigree here
you've got a phd in tropical ecology
from the university of cambridge
right and you specialized in the
underground
fungal networks in the tropical forests
of panama
this is just so exotic and like so fun
maybe i'd do this if i weren't an
astrophysicist so
can you just answer the question what
the hell is a mushroom
because it does it doesn't have leaves
it doesn't
you know it doesn't have photosynthesis
i think most people don't know what they
are
so please illuminate us
so mushrooms are the fruiting bodies of
fungi and fungi are a kingdom of life so
that's the broader category as animals
or plants
so fungi are a much bigger
world than just mushrooms only a few
fungal species
a few tens of thousands produce
mushrooms
but most live their lives as branching
fusing networks of tubular cells
known as mycelium wow
so so when did you know when i grew up
there was there was no mushroom kingdom
all right that's how old i am so when
did mushrooms decide
when did that happen please they um
well they won their independence
taxonomically speaking in the late 60s
wow so that's not quite in the textbooks
that i would have had because that's how
old i am
interesting and so what were they
considered before they were their own
kingdom just plants
yeah so unglamorous lower plants
lower cp back then everyone was putting
higher and lower they always got to
rank things that way that's just that's
that's not that's not right
they did that um and so
but but it's nonetheless a plant i mean
it grows out of the ground so when i
think of the animal kingdom
and the plant kingdom you're saying now
the word plant
does not include these spores that rise
up out of the ground that we call
mushrooms
that's right so fungi are more closely
related to animals than plants and they
also
behave more like animals in their
nutritional strategies
they don't plants photosynthesize they
they build the energy
that they need from sun and carbon
dioxide in the process of photosynthesis
but animals
have to find food ready-made in the
world which they then digest and fungi
have to do that too
so they're what's known as heterotrophs
wow
now i think i knew that about their
relationship but i knew it only sort of
indirectly when i looked at the tree of
life what i learned was that the common
ancestor
between mushrooms and all animal life
split later than that common ancestor
split from green plants
and that blew my mind because i think
that allows me to say what you just said
that mushrooms and animals are more
closely related that either of them are
to green plants that am i allowed to say
that upon knowing this about the tree of
life
yes damn
okay so now so this is so they grow and
and but they also
uh and we can eat them just as food or
we can
ingest them
who's who did the experiments to find
out
that mushrooms can affect us
psychologically is someone just going
there
how does that work in practice well it's
a good question
so the until the um early part of the
20th century
that only a few pockets of humans on the
planet knew that
some species of mushroom produced
psychoactive compounds and would eat
these mushrooms as part of their
ritual and spiritual practices that
knowledge then spread
to the west um and
after that point this handful of
tropical species
from mexico were known to produce
psilocybin mushrooms but but once that
became common knowledge
then people started to look all around
the world and now over 200 species
of fungi are known to produce psilocybin
and it's very interesting that process
because you know how how do you know
um people test them psilocybin bruises
blue when you
um when you crush the the mushroom and
so you can sometimes have a clue
from the color you can have a clue from
which species are closely related to
each other or not and which ones you
might reasonably expect
to be trippy um but there are always
some surprises
so this this chemical silicibin
psilocybin so has that been has that
been
isolated so that now you don't actually
have to grow the mushroom you just get
it out of somebody's laboratory
that's right it was actually first
isolated and named by
albert hoffman the guy who discovered
lsd
but now in many of the studies they're
being carried out they use pure
crystalline psilocybin produced in a lab
so he discovered it not while he was
under the influence of lsd presumably
because that
completely messes with your capacity to
think
well and interpret reality i i haven't
heard that he was on lsd while he was
taking it but you never know
so how complicated is it to synthesize
is it yeah can we just do that now again
like in my kitchen
what do i need well you need to i would
have thought that the easier way to get
solace ivan in your kitchen would be to
find a mushroom that has it rather than
setting up the lab but maybe i'm wrong i
have a big chemistry kitchen you don't
know you don't know
that's very true i'm talking about the
average person's kitchen
yeah no i mean it's definitely true it's
easier to grow them grow the mushrooms
than it would be to set up a lab
and go through all the analytic
procedures required to isolate
uh synthesize and isolate the molecule
so tell me about this and then we'll go
straight to questions after this because
i'm just so i just want to
lay some groundwork here this uh
mycelium
so i hosted this series on cosmos
and we spent an entire episode most of
an episode
talking about the mycelium but at the
time i didn't
uniquely associate it with mushrooms
themselves i
thought of it as just sort of this plant
network where all the plants are sort of
communicating
but are you saying mushrooms have their
own mycelium or they participate in a
larger mycelium of the
plant kingdom as well so mycelium is a
fungal
talent and not a plant palette and so
fungi make mycelium some of those fungal
species produce mushrooms that we see
many of them don't produce mushrooms
these different fungal species whether
they produce mushrooms or not
um some of them will relate to have
relationships intimate trading
relationships with plants
and so plug into plants and they
exchange nutrients
and some of those fungal networks can
plug into multiple plants at the same
time and those plants are also
promiscuous and plug into multiple
fungal networks and the result is shared
overlapping networks of plants and fungi
and that's what's
referred to and by the wood wide web how
do you think what you meant
the wood wise the wood wide web so i i
think that's what it was yeah i'm
curious about something just um
i i have we have this impression that uh
fungi
just sort of spontaneously appear uh
because you know if if you leave food in
the fridge for too long it gets moldy
um i once lived in a pretty grotty
shared house where we broke the toilet
at a party and then a week later because
no one fixed it there were mushrooms
growing
out of the carpet so that kind of thing
can happen uh
how many spores of fungi are just
generally in the air all the time
because there must be the spores
originally for them to then
land on something and then start to grow
lots
um in fact fungal spores exactly how
many
lots yeah well i mean so i got a number
if you want that
um 50 million tons of fungal spores are
produced and released into the air every
year which is the weight of 500 000 blue
whales
and these spores are such a large
presence in in the atmosphere that they
can
um they can precipitate the water
droplets that go on to form clouds and
rain so they can change the weather
wow okay just in case people don't know
you can more readily formula
uh generate a raindrop if there's
something to nucleate the condensation
on and that it greatly enhances that
process so yeah so i didn't know so it's
raining mushrooms is what you're telling
us
i'm glad i asked that now because that
was a hell of an answer that was yeah
that was great
let's go to questions uh matt all right
well
well there's a couple that neil's
already touched on with his questions
but
i just want a slightly more specific
answer from uh
teresina rojas's question what are the
differences between plants and fungi
and then and then also which ones evolve
first i believe the answer to that is
mushrooms are built first and fungi
involved first no
plant plants i think right so we'll let
him answer the questions
matt and i agree to shut up merlin go
for it
um so so plants uh photosynthesize
fungi don't photosynthesize and have to
find food and digest it
um and so what are they eating what what
is the food
well they can eat many things they're
the great decomposers of the planet
um they underwrite much of the
regenerative capacity of the biosphere
because of their voracious appetites
so um wood for example
if fungi didn't decompose wood then the
earth would be piled kilometers deep
in unrotted forests but they can also
eat
all sorts of unusual things there's a
specialist mold that lives in canadian
distilleries off the vapors evaporating
from whiskey barrels
as they age and there's a fungus called
the kerosene fungus which lives in the
fuel tanks of aircraft
so they have that they have a wide
variety of wow
different appetites you know they if
they wanted to they could just be our
overlords from what you're describing
here
yeah totally or underlords
[Laughter]
but that does connect a bit to a low
rosie's
question but starts with very nice
things saying big fans of the show
and then asks mushrooms are not only
very resilient to extreme conditions
they also have the ability to spread
even when they're technically inactive
and
to thrive when can and i believe thrive
is there's a typo there when conditions
become bearable again
in that respect do we know if mushroom
spores can survive the vacuum of space
and if yes can we imagine them seeding
distance planets and making a better job
of surviving than the human race
so fungal spores are really tough and
and some of them can
survive these um extraterrestrial
conditions
other types of fungal organism can too
lichens which are a symbiotic organism
a combination of fungi and bacteria and
algae
they can and they're some of the
hardiest organisms
known and when they're taken to
extraterrestrial conditions they're
suspended on the outside of the
international space station in trays
known as the expose
facility um but they're they dry out
uh very quickly of course in the vacuum
of space but then they can withstand the
radiation and the temperature swings
and when you bring them back to earth
they rehydrate and get on with living
and so there are different aspects of
the fungal kingdom
different parts of the fungal kingdom
can can withstand these um
these extreme conditions so they don't
need spacesuits is what you're telling
us no
okay actually i didn't know the space
station had sort of an outdoor tray
for the vacuum of space experiment lab
uh i didn't know that that's cool
they've also tested them in the mars
simulation facility
um where you can just put them in the
box and turn on mars
and you can just dial up or dial down
the radiation
um to test them to the utmost limits of
survival pretty useful
man i have a whole new respect for
mushrooms now damn
okay matt keep them coming okay so alec
asks
alec from the oregon coast says hi from
there uh and hope
we're all doing well and how long have
fungi been on the earth
and does that give a glimpse into what
prehistoric
does that give a glimpse into what
prehistoric animals might have eaten
so um general consensus
from fossils and from looking at the dna
is that fungi have been around for just
over a billion years
but mysterious fossils bearing an
uncanny resemblance to mycelial fungi
have been found in lava deposits dating
from over 2 billion
years ago and it's not clear whether
they were true fungi or not but they
suddenly look like funky and if they
were funky it would totally off-end
everything that's thought about the
history of multicellular life
and so but do you think mushrooms would
have been a part of
early animal diets oh
yeah for sure i mean
i don't see why animals would neglect
these nutritious delicious
organisms growing up within easy reach
would an animal knowingly
an animal not human knowingly eat a
mushroom that has psychedelic properties
it's a very good question i was talking
to michael
michael buech who runs the um toxicology
reports for the north american
mycological association
and he has a number of reports of dogs
that watch their owners picking
psychedelic mushrooms and after watching
them would also eat the psychedelic
mushrooms and and
it would appear to be under the
influence there was only one example of
a cat
that repeatedly ate its own psychedelic
mushrooms and appeared to be
mushroomed in his words see i think i
think cats are always eating mushrooms
based on behavior
patterns that i've seen i have no idea
how you would tell with my cat whether
he's taking anything that's what i'm
saying
ed before we go to break let me just uh
understand this
the pronunciation of the plural of
fungus
uh i i've heard fungi and
fungi how do they how do the italians
say it
italians say fungi fungi i say fungi
but people say fungi people say fungi
and it's really up to you oh okay i'm
glad to hear that because i think i've
said at least three different versions
in the course of just the last 15
minutes all right
so i will do as the romans do and call
it a
fungi is that correct that's what i'll
do
i don't know about matt i don't know
where his allegiances
are are found but i'm going with fungi
and just before we
cut here i just want to finish out some
of your resume uh it's interesting here
you're on the
board of the advisory board of the
fungi foundation that's great that's
just sounds like
that on a business court car you know
advisor to the fungis you know it's just
it just sounds so
so otherworldly if you will
and the society for the protection of
underground networks what do you do
there prevent people from putting
pesticides or something or herbicides
so i didn't know the underground
networks needed a lobby
you know lobbyists yeah well part of
it's just mapping the
mapping the networks around the world um
what type of fungal networks
and fungal networks interacting with
bacterial species and plant species
do you find in different places because
obviously we can't know what damage
we're doing until we know
what's there but it's very clear that we
will be damaging these networks
but it doesn't feel like they care about
i mean well let me
not speak for them for the mushrooms let
me just say broadly
if they are all over the place then why
should it matter to us if we dig up some
ground over here and not over there i
mean what is what is it you're actually
trying to protect
so many fungal networks enable plant
life plant life would be inconceivable
without the fungi that live in their
roots without the fungi that live in
their leaves and in their shoots
and in fact plants would have wouldn't
have evolved if it hadn't been for their
relationships with fungus
so if we depend uh our say on an
ecosystem a forest
for various reasons um then and we kill
all the fungi in the
forest then we're making a trouble
trouble for ourselves
and for everyone else who lives in the
forest so um
there are lots of reasons to so some
some fungi are able to withstand
intense conditions but many fungi aren't
and so um it's for these fungi that
we need to be mindful got it got it okay
and that's part
this is the perennial challenge of
anything we do to the environment
because one thing depends on another
depends on another
and ultimately it comes back to bite us
in the ass
right so exactly and then the most
worrying things are the unknown unknowns
and there's so much of fungal life we
don't understand there's so much of
microbial life we don't understand
um and so in kind of a race to to just
to get a picture of what
everyone's doing so that we um can avoid
making even more catastrophic mistakes
that's why we have you we'll see okay
so let's take a break here and when we
come back we're gonna find out more
of what our fan base wants to know
about mushrooms their psychedelic
properties and anything
else that mushrooms have been hiding
from us for a billion years
on star talk we're back
star talk cosmic queries we're talking
about mushrooms everything
you ever wanted and never wanted to know
about them it's going to happen
in this show i got with me my co-host
matt kirschen matt what
what's your your social media handle
that you want to put out there
oh uh matt kirschen uh on twitter and
matt underscore cursion on instagram but
i very rarely use that twitter's the one
to look at
okay christian uh k-r-k-i-r-s-h-e-n but
if you um
if you just if you're not sure just bang
anything close to that into google and
it'll find me
that's very confident of you okay they
just they just aren't many of us there's
there's very few mackerson's in the
world of anything
way back i get it so for this mushroom
expertise we've got merlin sheldrank
who's got a book out
uh just now in paperback entangled life
how make our world change our minds and
shape our futures this is an
audacious title i'm loving every minute
of it so merlin
uh great to have you are you active on
social media as well i think i saw you
have a twitter handle merlin sheldrake
yeah and instagram my name and
instagrams yeah there's no other merlin
shelters in the world yeah
i mean did your parents have very high
expectations for you
you know i'm not sure um they said that
they were calling me martin after the
bird not after the wizard
but i i complained that i didn't think
they can really um
make that kind of distinction so let's
let's let's pick it up we're we're in
the middle of our
flow of questions and these are all
patreon members we used to
only lead off with patreon questions and
now they own the whole stash
so every one of these is from patreon
members i just want to publicly thank
them for their support it enables us to
do experiments
that might not otherwise be commercial
uh
thank you for that uh it keeps going
yeah and there's some great questions
that have come in from the patrons
including a couple of people have asked
about
the this phenomenon of fungi
taking over other animals so zack
metcalf
says um some species of i hope i'm
pronouncing this one correctly is it
cordyceps
fungi uh can infect insect hosts and
compel them to die in very specific
locations
the famous examples are infected
bulletins climbing trees and dying on
the undersides of leaves the ideal
location for spores to rot from their
skin and infect more ants below
how do they how do the fungi relay such
specific instructions to its insect
victims
is the electrochemistry of walking and
climbing really so straightforward as to
be hijacked by
fungus man and this they sound like
they they sound evil yeah
i mean that's quite a remarkable thing
to do
this is an evil set of species you got
here merlin
all right so what's going on there yeah
so first i
i wouldn't underestimate the metabolic
abilities of fungi so um they're
metabolic wizards and can do all sorts
of extraordinary things so even if it
was a complicated task to hijack an
insect and control its behavior with a
great deal of precision
which no doubt it is i wouldn't put that
past them
um and we don't need to try it because
we know that this takes place but
broadly speaking
i mean the degree of precision is
remarkable so you can have for example a
carpenter ant and
off your cordyceps fungus and the fungus
will grow into the ant to start growing
its way through its bodies for its legs
through its
cavities it won't grow into its brain
though which is interesting
um but and then it produces whatever it
does
it produces in the ant uh a irresistible
urge to climb upwards overwriting the
normal instinct of the ant which is just
staying
close to the ground for purposes of
safety so the ant
climbs up in a syndrome known as summit
disease and then it finds
at the nearest vein on the other side of
the leaf at exactly the right height
for the fungus to fruit in the case of
offia cordyceps and carpet ants about 25
centimeters off the floor of the forest
and then around noon the ant
performs a death grip and it grips on to
the
left vein and the objectives has um her
special needs
and um and then the air fungus kills the
ants and it grows a stalk out of the
ant's head and rains down spores on
unfortunate ants passing below
it grows out of its head yeah
and so the movie alien has nothing on
this
really because that's just coming out of
your belly that's the normal place you
might find something growing inside of
you
but it goes out of its head there are
lots of different ways that
lots of different fungi do it
differently there's fungi that infect
cicadas and it
causes the back third of the cicada's
body to break off and
and for the male cicadas to become
hypersexual despite the fact that their
genitals have long since crumbled away
and
the cicadas sprouts spores from this
broken back end of its body as it flies
around
erratically well we're in a cicada
invasion now in the northeast in the
united states you surely know that
i committed online that i said i would
eat three of them when
they finally uh came so you might want
to um watch out because the the master
sport are the funky that overtake these
cicadas and no doubt that we're doing it
right outside
um your house and they they do it they
produce psilocybin and also
an amphetamine so if you eat enough of
them then you might start feeling
stranger than you realize okay and i
might i might have accredited the
the the cicada but it was really the
invading
mushroom spores that would have done
you'd probably tweet quite a few before
you noticed that i think you'd be safe
yeah that's not happening no risk
eating any more than i that i'd uh
committed
well a related question well a related
question from teresina who asked earlier
was is it possible for
for a fungi to take over a control of a
relatively large animal
and to what extent do they influence our
own behavior
yeah how about mammals like small
mammals like um you know
under scurrying mice and things you know
field mice that sort of thing
so these fungi that take over insects
with this great precision
and none of them are known to take out
animals and mammals mammals
are a bit trickier because we have a
higher body temperature which gene tends
to put off
funky doesn't always put them off and
there are a number of fungi that can
cause a big
problem in an animal body in a human
body but there aren't any
examples of quite such specific um
alterations there are fungi that will
infect you and cause a life-threatening
disease and make you feel strange and
will change your behavior because it's
made you sick but
not that will grow inside you and puppet
your behavior um
or make you climb up a tree and scatter
spores out of your abdomen
so when i was doing that i can't blame
that on any kind of uh fungi
[Laughter]
yep that's that's you got to own that
one matt that's all you do
so what i got one for you and i want to
pretend i'm a patreon member now
so if you ever get what they call
athlete's feet the cure for that is
anti-fungal
cream so are you telling me if i have
athlete's feet i have fungus growing in
my toes
that's right it's one of these things
you study
this is your fault you you your
your species your families of species
are giving me athlete's feet that's what
you're saying either neil i mean
your subject matter wiped out the
dinosaurs
you got me there
i got no comeback on that okay we have
an asteroid the size of mount everest
that took out a whole str 70 of earth
species okay
all right i i take it back but that is a
kind of mushroom is what you're saying
it's a fungus it doesn't produce
mushrooms but it but it is sorry
mushroom is the fruit but it's a fungus
yeah i gotcha damn so so gordon
patreon patron gordon vu asks something
related says i suffered from jock itch
which i believe is the same or i think
that's the same uh fungus
and the doctor said it was a fungal
infection does this fungus grow
elsewhere besides the human body you
know this is too much information about
this guy's hygiene
do we really have to find out he puts
out his name
and he's telling the world he's got jock
itch it's all science
okay it's for science very good okay we
have we have a devoted
following so there he didn't even say i
have a friend
who has jock itch he didn't even say
that i think i think that's worse though
i think if you know about your friend's
jock itch
that's a good point what the hell are
you doing
knowing about your friend's jocket okay
so
so is that is it the same species
because what's interesting merlin i
learned
is that head lice is a different
subspecies of lice than um
a genital ice so
i couldn't tell you whether they're the
same i suspect that they're
slightly different and i couldn't tell
you whether or not it um it lives in
other places but
it's very common for funky to to be able
to live in different situations if you
have an oyster mushroom mycedium that
would grow on a book that would grow on
used cigarette butts
if you do train is in the right way it
could grow on grains it could grow on
um logs of wood so many fungi have
catholic tastes and it's possible so i
can't say
for sure because i don't know um the
jock itch
species also lives in other places
you're giving no reason to think they'd
be different
right right i think it was an oyster
mushroom that was growing out of our
carpet
after a week or so after the toilet was
broken at the party
would that be plausible it look it
certainly looked oyster like it was a
surprisingly large mushroom that had
appeared in our house
in a place that shouldn't have been in
this gross place that i live back in my
early matt when you climb the tree
you sport out the the i know we
shouldn't put the tree in the toilet
either that was a that was another
mistake that's the first giveaway right
there
all right man give me some more well so
gordon goes on to actually ask
uh i'm curious if there are telltale
sell uh
signs to differentiate between an edible
and poisoned mushroom
and why are some mushrooms poisonous and
others not that's a good question i
you know because matt i mean why i mean
if if
if i mean a mushroom is a mushroom i
guess maybe a mushroom is just not a
mushroom yeah a little different
that's always been you know i i've been
curious about that because i know there
are people you know mushroom foraging is
a big thing people foraging for
for cooking reasons and then also people
who are foraging for more party reasons
but
in either case the the the warning has
always been well you better make sure
you know what you're getting because if
you pick up the wrong one then you can
be in some real trouble
right so we have uh healthy poisonous
and psychedelic
so how does the mushroom kingdom divide
up
well some mushrooms will will kill you
and so you definitely need to know your
money
to eat them
but at least they won't kill me by
having something grow out of my head
it's just a regular old poison
i i'd rather that than be humiliated
by having spores come out of my head i'm
sorry well they're
they're pretty deft uh some of them
you'll eat them but
deadly poisonous ones you might eat them
you'll feel pretty pretty bad for a
while then you'll get better
and then a day or so later you'll drop
dead it's called a false remission
um wow so they do have their methods
but um but there's no reliable trait
that you can use to distinguish poison
from poisonous from non-poisonous
across the board because lots of the
poisonous ones are poisonous in
different ways
often um and some of them it's not clear
you know this i had a professor
um a professor of history of science i
used to go out mushroom hunting with he
had a big collection of mycological
texts
and matt did you hear that i had a
profession
that i once went out okay
did the professor give you a bad grade
and we don't have the professor anymore
in the world
with your around us here i don't know
what what you got going there but go on
sorry to interrupt
so what he said was that i i said other
cases where the same mushroom species
is described by different um books in
radically different ways and he said
that there was a book a german
guidebook a hundred years old or so that
he had
and it described the yellow staining
mushroom which in english guide books
says poisonous don't eat as skull and
crossbones
stay clear in this german guidebook it
said delicious
and when fried lightly but might cause a
light coma
in those of weak constitution
mild coma that's all i know i mean like
it sounds quite fun doesn't it
but um not a heavy one just a light one
and and
it turns out that it depends on your
metabolism some people have the ability
to to
metabolize these toxins other people who
don't so even if you can tell what
mushroom you're eating
in rare cases um people will have
different reactions that very same
mushroom
it's a bit like plants you know plants
that will kill you some plants delicious
some plants people or some people are
allergic to
tomatoes you know that sort of thing i
guess you know okay
but that'd be a cap i guess it's all
chemical at the end of the day
but it's not a living thing that's
attacking you
for having consumed it all right i mean
in other words a poisonous mushroom
and you uh dying from eating peanuts
because you have a peanut
allergy these are different causes
correct
yeah because the peanuts won't kill
everyone but a poisonous mushroom
would kill everyone yeah an
authentically poisonous mushroom
if you ate sufficient quantity yeah yeah
all right all right matt we got time for
one more before we
hit a break and then come to our final
segment so what do you have
so isaac lambert asks how much faster is
mycelium in plants fungi and trees than
the neurons in our brain
i didn't even know that they were faster
than the neurons in our brain oh
oh i mean is and is a neurological
analog sensible here
so um some fungi
produce waves of electrical activity
analogous to the
impulses that travel in our nerves which
is a fascinating finding which
um might really shake up the way we
think about um the communication
and that fungi can can conduct and the
way that they connect other organisms
together
and so given that some fungi do produce
impulses electrical impulses
and then when you look at it you have
our nervous systems which contain
um long electrically excitable cells and
you have fungal networks which are
networks of long
electrically excitable cells and on a
superficial level there are some
similarities the neurons in our bodies
conduct impulses or action potentials
very much faster
than those that you find in some fungal
networks
because remember not all funky do this
only some do so
um there's a big difference in speed but
then again
we have a need for much faster speeds we
live
at a faster pace because we're
locomoting we're moving or twitching
much richie muscular bodies so
so we need that speed but the funky uh
made made you perfectly well without
that
because fast lane compared with
mushrooms
that's not gonna think about that all
right so slip one more in matt before we
hit the break
uh tarasina asks are there any naturally
occurring networks of bioluminescent
fungi
in fact i just know i was just notified
we have to take the break but let's hold
on to that
and i think they call that a tease is
that right bioluminescent
bio chemical pathways when we return
from this break
on star talk cosmic queries all about
mushrooms
we're back again merlin sheldrake
one of the world's experts in mushrooms
and he did that on purpose like got his
phd
and studied it and everything and so
that makes him really useful to people
who have their own relationship with
mushrooms
and matt apparently you grew mushrooms
in your toilet
and yeah i really want to know about
that any any mushroom cultivation in my
life has been entirely
uh unintentional
okay so what's that last question you
had about bioluminescence i love it so
are there
naturally occurring bioluminescent fungi
yes is the answer there are a number of
species of bioluminescent fungi some
produce
the mushrooms that bioluminesce and some
produce mycelium
that bioluminescence like
bioluminescences in fact
um the first ever submarine called the
turtle which was invented during the
american revolutionary war
that um a fungally bioluminescing
bits of wood were used to illuminate the
depth gauge of the turtle
known as fox fire this particular sort
[Music]
so we knew about that and how to then
exploit it so
so we early on you're saying we
weaponized bioluminescent mushrooms
well i don't know how effective the
title was
[Laughter]
nonetheless we weaponized it okay what
did it
did offered the british but um
wow okay very cool and by the way this
all sounds like
the the the the tree of life mapping
for james cameron's movie
for avatar right these are he's trying
to come up with exotic life
and he gets all the most exotic life on
earth and makes that the regular life
over there except they have like usb
ponytails where they can connect and
talk to the animals all right is that
the mushrooms have that too i just
i want to know how quickly they
exactly exactly yeah well they do they
grow into the plants and they kind of
plug in if you want to use the the
electronics metaphor
but the plugging in involves growing
into a plant root growing in and around
plant cells it's a very intimate
embrace and and i guess you can think
about that in an analogous term to the
way that the um
the plugging in happens in avatar the
fungal
networks in avatar are based on on the
fungal networks in the real world
scientifically right because uh james
cameron you know he has many movies
including the abyss uh movies where he
has cared about the science
of what surrounds his storytelling and
then he puts it in
as uh as best as he's able
so keep it coming matt all right well uh
chas jen corelli i hope i'm pronouncing
your name
even at least vaguely closer correctly
asks why are there so many different
types of fungi still being discovered
each year
was that right you guys are not on top
of everything
no so there's an estimated um two to
three million species of fungi on the
planet
and only about 150 000 have been
described and that means
that six to eight percent of the total
number of fungal species on the planet
have been described and that obviously
leaves over 90 percent
undescribed and and there's so it's a
lot of work for
fungal taxonomies to do just very basic
descriptive work
that hasn't been done for a number of
reasons and one of the reasons is
because
fungi were thought to be plants for a
very long time and so
they didn't get a kingdom's worth of
attention um
from from biologists another reason is
that they live
hidden lives they live as mycelial
networks which are buried in whatever
they're eating
mycelium is how fungi feeds so they've
got to insinuate themselves in their
food to digest it and what that means is
that
usually um we don't see so much of what
they're doing so it's harder for us to
access
see they're doing that on purpose they
don't want you
describing them i have the privilege of
having a species named after me a
species of frog
and so i looked at the the the
the species the species paper
the paper that makes it the species and
i was
astonished how much measurement went on
on that you know the the ratios of the
digits in the feet of the frog versus
the
hands and the eyes separation
all of this gets characterized i'm
thinking damn that must have taken a
long time
and if you've got like a gazillion
species left i'm not doing it to get
somebody else to do
it but it's it's it's there's only so
many tv scientists so how are you going
to even come up with little names
exactly exactly so i so it's the it's in
the irani
tysoni a species of leaping frog and so
i was very honored by that
wow you know linnaeus and lioness and
the taxonomist and um
buffon the french taxonomist has a big
rivalry and both would name
glamorous species after their patrons
and they would name unglamorous speeches
after each other because
the wolfrack was mufa buffa because
linnaeus thought that he'd
get one over on buffalo
is neil is your frog is it is it a
glamorous frog or is it an unglamorous
frog
i was just happy that it was a
vertebrate you know because they're like
bugs and stuff and
and slime mold and bacteria
i'm sure those are wanting for names but
at least i got a vertebrate i'm just
putting it out there right now i would
be honored to have a slime named after
me
if there's any slime scientists there
i'll take any species
of any kingdom
the request is out in the in the
mycelium we'll see who comes back on it
all right so matt what do you have so
i've saved these two towards the end
because i i think they're they're
connected and they're a big topic that i
think a lot of people are interested in
when we talk about mushrooms and
particularly talk about magic mushrooms
so bo shankar asks is merlin familiar
with terence mckenna and his views on
magic mushrooms could magic mushrooms
have expanded the human mind
introducing complex language and culture
to early humans through psychedelic
experience and then robert schlosser
asks how much of an impact would you
speculate
has psilocybin had on human evolution i
think they're playing in similar worlds
like
those two together interesting yeah so
these are
these it's a great question um without a
clear answer it's very hard to know one
way or another when we're going back
into
prehistory i mean it seems clear to me
that psychedelics
including psychedelic mushrooms have had
a very big impact on human
culture um and for an unknowably long
time
and of course culture and nature are
categories that we create but they
aren't separated by an unbreachable
divide anthropogenic climate change is a
good example of how cultural
developments in
in humans can affect what we think of as
the natural world
out there terence's claim terence
mckenna's claim
with the stoned ape hypothesis was that
eating magic mushrooms had caused human
brains to increase in size
or primate brains yeah the pre-human
brains
and this is um this is a big claim it's
unlikely we'll know either way there's
certainly something to be explained um
so between 3 million years ago
and 200 000 years ago when when
we're informed that what we think that
um homo sapiens first arose
the primate brains that led to us
increased by four times so quadrupled in
size
they grew to four times the size that
they had grown in the previous 60
million years
of primate evolution this is sometimes
called the brain boom
and it's known as took place the fossil
record is clear the question is why
there are a number of hypotheses brains
a really hungry
hungry organ it makes up only it makes
up two percent of our body mass but
takes 20 percent of our energy at rest
so i think one of the persuasive
um the persuasive hypotheses is that
the domestication of fire helps because
once you can cook food then we have to
eat less of it we have to spend less
time foraging we can supply more energy
to
a hungry organ like the brain and
terence said that this was
brought about by the mushrooms uh maybe
a little bit maybe some maybe not i mean
it's psilocybe is being shown to
increase nerve branching in dishes in
culture but that doesn't necessarily
suggest that it would increase
brain size over time in real life humans
there are different versions of the
stoned eight hypothesis some of them
suggest
that the big developments like
symbolic language and other
major milestones in human cognition
arose through psychedelics i think
that's more plausible than the brain
increase argument i understand if it's a
temporary condition
put on your brain chemistry how does
that make any kind of biological
evolution at all
i don't know so i think so terrence
isn't here to defend it but
but what he might say it would be that
um there are epigenetic shifts
that would be carried over um or
that the um that there are cultural
changes which then go on to increase our
brain size so
if you you can imagine a hypothetical
situation where someone took magic
mushrooms had the idea to domesticate
fire domesticated fire
had cooked food and then that allowed
our brains to increase in size
so this chemical can
give you brilliant ideas because what i
understand the brain is pretty
it barely works as it does right now
you're going to toss in some extra
chemicals
that will alter your perception of
reality and you want to claim that
you're now closer
to nature so so just sorry to
jump in is is the claim kind of just i'm
trying to
untangle it but the claim isn't that the
mushrooms themselves grow the brain but
the mushrooms
expand your horizons that make you then
think of doing things that then down the
line cause your brain to increase in
size is that
so yeah so the different versions of the
standard then and so some of them would
say that the mushrooms themselves
cause an increase in nerve growth and
that somehow passed on
intergenerationally
and some of them i think the more
plausible ones would say
that um the the experience the radically
altered
cognitive experience the unconstrained
style of cognition that you have when
under the influence of mushrooms
and gives you new ideas and behavior
invites you to behave in new ways
and possibly synesthetic ways which
might give rise to
certain ways of using language or sounds
and associating those with meanings for
example
has that happened to you in other words
have you had a deep thought
that you're pretty sure you wouldn't
have had had you not exposed yourself
to psychedelic mushrooms
yes in a word yes um
so you'd recommend everyone do it then
no i wouldn't i wouldn't do that
why if if it made you smarter or more
insightful in your own work
uh why not just recognize that you know
have it over the counter at the pharmacy
well these experiences can be somewhat
unruly and so you'd want to be sure that
you're taking it
in the right frame of mind in the right
setting
um and some people might have
constitutions that would not agree with
this kind of
radical alteration in their experience
and they'd be wise to stay clear
other people might need certain kinds of
supervision um it's not a
straightforward process
so i wouldn't recommend that everyone
everyone took them i think many people
can certainly benefit from psychedelic
experiences which is why it's exciting
to see
this new wave of research into
psychedelic compounds pick up steam
there you go well there is this isn't
one of the patreon
questions but i know there's been quite
a bit of research recently there's been
a fair few news stories that have come
out of late
into how psychedelic treatments
might be beneficial for certain types of
depression yeah i've seen more articles
on that that's right
so i it's it's one thing to know that
it's there and it's psychedelic but
it's quite a whole other exercise to
take this chemical and see how it can be
absorbed
up up took into civilization in ways
that can serve our needs
yeah i mean the thing to remember is
that these psychedelic compounds whether
from fungi or from plants
or from animals they've been really
major parts
of traditional human societies for a
very very long time
and so um it's not like this is
news in the big picture of of human
existence
it's just this new way that science is
finding to describe
quantify and make sense of these
experiences within the framework of
modern medical pathology uh modern
illnesses and
treatment programs one final question
then because this is tarisina sent in a
bunch and this is the last question that
we have
and this is how can we take advantage of
the properties
of the fungi network to combat climate
change
and can we even is i possibly a bigger
question
yeah if it's if the field is in its
infancy in in a way
there could be so much potential if
people are thinking the right way about
it or you bring
people from other disciplines to then
help
explore what applications might exist
that would be invisible to someone who's
really close to the problem
yeah there's an explosion of interest in
in fungal applications at the moment
and many of them to do with the ways
that funky can help us adapt
to the um the climate change problem or
problems rather
so there are a number of ways you can
think about it um there are fungal
medicines that can um that can help
humans recover from illnesses but also
can help other animals the mycologist
paul stamets has done some amazing work
showing that
fungal extracts can help bees
overcome viral pathogens
and so extend the lifetime of bees and
beehives which in turn
can help us adapt to changing climates
and changing pressures on
pollination schemes and there are also
fungal materials built using mycelium
which can help disrupt polluting
plastics industries
um can create sustainable materials for
use in in buildings or structures but
also
for clothing and kind of method-like
material
fungi in agriculture and forestry we're
never going to not need to grow trees
and
plants and fungi are fundamental to all
plant life so other ways that we can
change our behavior so that the plants
and fungi can better support each other
in these changing situations we find
ourselves in
um there are fungal foods are there new
types of
ways that we can grow so proteinaceous
um delicious meat substitutes using
mycelium
and which would relieve our dependence
on on
unsustainable meat farming there are
many such examples there are also ways
that
that climate change might make things
worse in conjunction with the funky um
so
some fungal pathogens of plants for
example might be able to move into new
areas when climates change and whole
swathes of forests might become
vulnerable to new fungal pathogens it's
already happening
and killing off huge areas of forest
which would then be decomposed by other
types of fungi
and lots of co2 will then be emitted
into the
atmosphere so it's not a straightforward
story about fungal saviors
fungi are startlingly ingenious
opportunists and as things change
and they will be able to move into new
niches and and maybe sometimes
that will be good for us and sometimes
less good do you have any party thoughts
for us about
uh as we go forward um any advice any
uh bits of wisdom you have gleaned from
this
mycelial madness well you know neil
one thing i i've often thought about
because these fungal networks
are astonishing and and and raise all
sorts of questions about how life works
um but one of the things that's been
interesting recently maybe you'll be
able to tell me a bit more about it is
that
the cosmic web the very structure of the
universe is now thought to be made up of
big filaments
of gas and galaxies arranged in clusters
linked together in this way so i would
say
um as below so above when i'm looking at
these fungal networks and thinking about
the structure of the universe presumably
you would say as above
so below well okay i can i'm happy to
say that they
look alike right the the cosmic web that
they speak of but a web
implies some coherence to what's going
on
and in this cosmic web the distances
between nodes
is so far
that even at the speed of light an
appreciable fraction of the age of the
universe has to go by before
it could communicate with another if we
want to use the word communicate
so for so we have we have galaxy
clusters that are so large
they're clearly together but
it can take the age of the universe for
any one galaxy to cross
and get to the other side well that's
really
that's the slow boat all right so it's
not
authen it's not legitimate to think of
these
as functioning systems if if we're
limited by the speed of light
of course as we expect that they are
whereas your mycelium and
everything else that's sort of
terrestrial or smaller yeah you could
have interconnectivity
on the time scale of the lifespan of the
organism you're talking about
so just because things look the same
doesn't always mean they are the same
and i say in this case that's one of
those examples yeah i mean
i didn't i didn't think for a moment
that the um the cosmic web
and the oyster mushroom mycedium were
were the same but but it would be cool
if they were if the mushrooms in fact
were communicating with the galaxies so
matt that's
we just give up at that point we got no
hope
as humans in this universe the day we
discover that mushrooms are controlling
galaxies
all right guys we got to call it quits
there so merlin thank you for
coming on to star talk uh all the way
from london and
we're going to follow your work and just
in case you discover some new mushroom
and you want to tell everybody about it
you can do it here first we can
get it we've got some new got some new
fancy mushrooms got new properties
uh we'll we'll take that interview and
matt always good to have you dude oh
it's good to be here and i'm fascinated
i want to know more about i'm getting
this book because
i feel like we've not even scratched the
surface no of course not of course not
right that's not possible for something
that complex all right so
merlin when the mushrooms become our
overlords
i think see matt i think he's practicing
for that so that he
won't get con keep him as their pet and
they'll
eat the rest of us you see that's how
that'll work i think they've already
infected me which is why
this has been star talk and i'm neil
degrasse tyson as always bidding you
to keep looking up
[Music]